just I just really didn't have a clue
you are grabbing yeah it kind of worked
out for her worked out perfectly
I had the best childhood I loved my
childhood I had a very happy childhood
and we would have the best days yeah it
was absolutely like some of the best
times my life even that amazing but I
was fine
I felt good it's nuts being a mom guys
raising kids is an amazing experience I
did some mistakes but by the end I can
see it's not as met they survived in
spite of us nail thank goodness haha you
know she turned out to be the wonderful
woman that she is I think she's perfect
the love that you had when that kid was
born and that you didn't have it is a
miracle
it's the wife that she is on the mother
that she isn't I'm really proud of just
her oh yeah
she's so good like I'm oh so good yeah
thanks mommy
so I think she's the best mom in the
world thank oh I wish I you know I'd
been more like that oh I love you I love
you I love you mommy
oh you said it would be fun Milo chance
imagine America
you